c'est ici en 2024 que le commissariat
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines verra le jour
à la place du complexe de tennis
d'elancourt cet établissement
centralisera l'activité des 300
policiers du commissariat d'elancourt de
guyancourt et de trappes tout en
conservant une présence dans chaque
commune ce nouveau commissariat nous
permettra d'une meilleure coordination
dans le travail une organisation plus
efficiente au sein de nos unités une
meilleure coordination de travail
notamment entre les unités de voie
publique et les différents services
d'investigation qui sont amenés à
travailler bien évidemment ensemble des
groupes de travail rassemblant des
équipes du ministère de l'intérieur font
régulièrement des réunions
objectif déterminer les besoins des
futurs membres du commissariat
d'agglomération d'elancourt c'est un
commissariat innovante puisque il doit
servir à améliorer les relations police
population mais également les relations
police partenaire de la police nationale
et améliorer également la qualité de vie
au travail des fonctionnaires de police
notamment par l'ensemble de ces
innovations technologiques des
équipements technologiques avec un
développement du numérique dans
l'activité des policiers
on pourrait imaginer aussi l'utilisation
de drones une perspective favorisée par
le tissu économique dans le secteur de
la défense sur le territoire beaucoup
d'entreprises travaillent sur sur ce ce
cette stratégie d'améliorer la sécurité
des français
c'est vraiment la sécurité de demain du
futur voilà donc c'est ce sera le ca va
être certainement un des prototypes un
des modèles de la sécurité de mai en
france
ce projet est le fruit d'une
collaboration entre l'état la région le
département et saint quentin en yvelines
l'investissement est estimé à 20
millions d'euros dans les prochaines
semaines l'architecte sera choisi
la livraison est prévue fin 2023 début